i saw someone die late last night
[Music]
have you been taking your medication you
don't get it
she's here she followed
me here you're not in your right state
of mind
[Music]
yesterday we just dropped the short film
you monster on the corridor channel now
this piece explores how audiences
affect creators and we're gonna sit down
with anthony padilla who plays the lead
character ashton
now he's a veteran of the youtube game
he's had an audience for years
we're gonna see how the themes of this
piece resonate with his personal life
and experiences
what we shot this piece back in november
and then uh there's been a worldwide
pandemic
and a large uh movement against police
brutality since then
has it ever felt appropriate to release
this i mean even now it's like
damn the world is just very different
than it was eight months ago when we
shot it
yeah you know but it's one of those
things where i don't want to keep
sitting on it i just want to put it out
there because
you know the question this piece asks is
how does an audience change
things you know sometimes for the worse
sometimes for the better you know you're
somebody who's had an audience you've
had an audience for a long time i mean
you're you're a veteran of
of the industry at this point you took
part this project you know you brought
your acting towns to the table obviously
your friends would go back a ways but
was there anything that
spoke to you personally in this is there
anything that like stood out as a
message that you that made you
interested
yeah i mean i i think the whole concept
of
an audience wanting you to document
things
and people who you know get obsessed
with these numbers and engagement it
becomes very easy
as someone who does social media to
start gravitating toward the things that
get you the most engagement the most
viewership
because that translates to success
in all the different ways i feel like a
lot of people get in their head i'll use
these cheap tactics
whenever i can because it'll allow me to
do more things it'll unlock more
doors for me in the future i don't think
it's necessarily
malicious i don't think there's this
intent to do things that are inherently
evil but i think some people get
just blinded by the opportunities that
success can open up have you ever found
yourself doing something
or not doing something specifically
because you have
an audience i think there was a time you
know when
when things started becoming more what
some people call pc culture
and there was a time where i made really
edgy jokes because i thought they were
funny because they were shocking
um and there was i think there was a
brief moment where i
didn't understand reasons for why
some things weren't appropriate but i
feel like i was
able to learn why it affected people and
in turn kind of become more empathetic
with why people you know found certain
things
offensive or why people should or
shouldn't say certain things
so i feel like over the years i've i've
started to
understand and learn more why things
affect people in different ways so
i don't find myself having to hold back
at all because i actually my mentality
my view of the things going on in the
world has just changed so drastically
since that time
when you can work that stuff into your
core and just be who you are
naturally that's you know that's the
best state you can possibly be in you
know with the role of the audience this
video obviously it casts a negative
light on how people can influence
uh and encourage people to do things
that they otherwise wouldn't do
but you know it's not all negatives you
know do you have any examples of
positives where you think you know an
audience putting attention onto
something has
has made things better yeah i mean i
think i think even right now with the
black lives matter movement with so much
focus on police brutality
and systemic racism and i think it's
really had a positive effect because
people have seen so much encouragement
from their audience
and just the media in general to to
speak up about these things so i think
there has been
some positivity yeah there's also been
negative too but i think in many ways
there has been a ton of positive what
what responsibility do you think an
audience has
uh to the content they consume it's
funny you ask that
the audience is in some ways directly
responsible for what kind of content
gets made
because you're voting with your view if
you want more content like that to be
made
if you're someone who hate watches
things you know you're like i hate this
so much but i love how much i hate it i
love
talking with my friends about how much i
hate it you're voting for more content
like that to be made
it's half the person who creates the
content and then it's half
the audience telling that creator that
they want more of that to be made
and then with their view also giving
them the money to fund
doing more of that as well it's a really
good insight on it i have to agree with
you it's definitely
it's like voting with your dollar except
you're voting with your view you know
people people feel like
there's a million people watching video
why would your view impact it but at the
same time i see
so many reminders of how small the world
is that one view does make a difference
that one comment you make does make a
difference it's small
but at the same time it's not small the
moment you get five 10
20 100 people saying the same thing 100
comments on a youtube video even if it's
a super popular one all saying the same
thing like at least for me
i noticed that creators take notice to
that um yeah
and i would say to people out there
don't get discouraged by how big the
numbers are keep in mind that an
individual
is still very powerful absolutely every
once in a while there's a single comment
that gives me some insight
into something either that i'm going to
do or something that i have done
that completely shifts my my perception
of the way that i would go about doing
that
and i think it's super important
everyone should be speaking up more if
they have something to say
i think that you know at least i think
you can speak to and i can speak to
is you do get a chance as a person with
an audience to refine yourself for the
better to
polish off those rough edges and get a
greater understanding of people
across all different walks of life and
how things work i think that's a
responsibility as a creator that you
bring to the table when you have an
audience you know that
it's important that you grow with that
audience to not only learn from the
audience but then take that learning
from the audience and give it back to
them that they can learn as well you
know it's all just one big circle of
education yeah absolutely i say like you
know look back at content that you used
to make 10 or 15 years ago or even
imagine that you are who you were 10 or
15 years ago and look at the content
that you make now and you could just see
how much
growth there has been and i'm sure a
huge part of that has been
interacting with your audience and
learning from them and then in turn kind
of shaping your view of the world at the
same time
yeah so to tie this back to you monster
when do you film and when do you help
when does it become not okay to continue
having your phone out and when do you
get involved if you were in a situation
let's say
you were witnessing a fight when do you
think it's okay to be recording it and
when do you think
a lion gets crossed and you should
either no longer be recording it or you
should step in
to do something about it it's best to
quickly assess the situation
am i safe would it be safe for me to
step in and if the answer is yes it
would be safe then you should definitely
go and help like in you monster my
character should have definitely
helped there was nothing that would have
hurt me
in going up and like helping that person
or talking to them or trying to
understand
what was going on in their mind but you
know say it's
an instance where there's some kind of
violence going on or
obviously police brutality you know i
think if you can't
directly contribute because it might be
putting your life in danger in some way
it would probably be best to record that
so you could show people and talk about
it and make it a bigger thing
with george floyd in that unfortunate
situation they
they didn't feel safe stepping in so i
think they did the best that they could
do and that was
document it so that it could spark a
discussion and in turn there's been an
entire
worldwide movement because of that so i
think those people did the best that
they could do with the situation that
they were in
yeah i think it's great insight and uh
good advice also you know i want to say
thank you again for getting involved in
this project for lending
you know your your talents on screen and
taking the time to
nail the character and help us make a
piece that's a little bit more than just
a vfx action scene
yeah absolutely i had a great time i
mean as a director you gave a lot of
freedom to uh
improvise it just you pulled something
that
feels so big together with such a small
crew and small budget
and uh i'm really really happy with how
it turned out so thank you for having me
be part of that you bet man
you know thanks for taking a minute of
your day here to talk to us and uh i
look forward to getting that video out
there and seeing what people think
absolutely man thank you and uh you know
thanks to the whole production team it
was a really fun time
i'd love to hear your thoughts i'd love
to hear if you think audiences bear any
responsibility in the content that is
created for them and if so what kind of
responsibility do they bear
have you ever personally been affected
by having an audience you know i know
not everybody out here has
you know say youtube channels or
instagram followings but even small
followings
has that shaped or changed the way you
approach life have you ever been
recording a video and been thinking to
yourself
i maybe should put my phone away and get
involved in some other way than just
filming it let me know in the comments
below i'd love to hear your stories i'd
love to hear your thoughts
i'd love for you to go check out
umonster it's it's a piece that we put a
lot of work into it's an idea i've had
for a long time
and you should also go check out
anthony's channel he does some awesome
eye-opening sit-downs where he talks to
really interesting people
so we'll have links for his stuff as
well all right happy watching